Jennifer Lopez and boyfriend Alex  Rodriguez enjoy some fun in the French  Sun the 47 year old singer and her 41  year old former MLB star are enjoying a  romantic getaway overseas the two were  spotted yachting in Antibes France on  Thursday  JLo flaunting her rockin bod in this  crochet one-piece her hair pulled back  in a pony while wearing her signature  aviator shades he loves it  while a rod opted for navy trunks and  dark shades Alaia Alaia puppets these  two sure seem to be happily in love and  are spending quite a bit of time  together on Saturday the pair headed to  the mainland where they enjoyed touring  the Louvre in Paris  et spoke with the Jennifer in may where  she gushed over their relationship he's  such a supportive person and he's so  lovely  you